so democrats used to oppose monopolies
only for like 100 years by the way if
it's left to this show to oppose
monopolies
something has gone very wrong by the way
it was just last year the republicans
joined by democrats issued a joint
statement condemning anti-trust abuses
by companies like
google and amazon one person who
supported that is tulsi gabbard she
still does she's a former democratic
congresswoman from hawaii and she joins
us tonight
to tell us what happened congressman
thanks so much for coming on so
this used to be literally from the
progressive era until yesterday
was at the center of the democratic
party's identity were against monopolies
when did that change and why
uh well first of all let's just be clear
from the outset
as we're seeing now once again how
dangerous these big tech
monopolies are and how imperative it is
that
we break them up that we actually bring
about solutions to break up the power
that they have
amassed i think the important thing is
that we do this
through legislative changes and reforms
uh not through throwing molotov
cocktails and and having riots and this
is where
exactly all of us come into play that we
as voters
we need to make sure that we are
choosing leaders who are
motivated by serving the american people
upholding our constitutional freedoms
and
and upholding our democracy uh more than
being motivated by
selfish interests and how do i please my
big tech
monopoly donors and this is where
um you know i think that there's a lot
of hopelessness right now and wondering
how do we do this hope can be found
in recognizing the power in our own
voices as voters that we really do
get to choose who holds these high
offices of power
and that we can make that decision by
saying hey you need to be someone who
i'm confident is committed to serving
the best interests of the american
people who's committed to upholding
our constitutional rights and freedoms
uh and you're not one of these people
these politicians who've existed for so
long
and and have been a part of the problem
because they're so addicted to getting
this money from these big tech
monopolies and therefore no matter how
much noise they make
about how you know hey this is a bad
thing when it comes right down to it
they don't actually do what it takes to
make the changes necessary
to work for us the american people
i don't understand why more people
aren't outraged by censorship if nancy
pelosi was shut down censored silenced
erased from the internet tomorrow i
don't care for nancy pelosi's views i
would swear as god watches i would
defend her
trump whatever you think of what he said
some of it i don't like
everybody everybody this is great i
support this people who should
ro khanna who's like a very smart guy
he's he's in favor of censorship like
what is this
it's it's really disheartening uh to see
how people are so inward looking at at
only supporting the voices of those who
agree with them rather than recognizing
the country that our founders envisioned
for all of us and
you as you know we've talked about this
before as a soldier this is something
that i take
to heart in a very deep way like every
other service member
that we take an oath to uphold our
constitution to to support and defend it
which includes supporting the freedom of
speech of
every single person in this country
whether we agree with that speech or not
whether that speech offends us
or not that is at the heart of this
country and who we are as americans and
we all must
stand up and support that and make sure
that we pressure our leaders
to do the same amen otherwise
what are people dying for i couldn't
agree more so nicely quit chelsea
gabbard thank you for coming
thank you tucker